[Music]
hey this is do you want robe with
collider and I'm at the collider studio
at the Kia Telluride supper suite at
Sundance and I'm here with the folks
behind horse-girl
let me start by saying how much I
enjoyed this movie I really dug this you
guys have the premiere tonight I think
that's right thank you right so how many
interviews have you done with people who
have actually seen it yesterday I I hate
asking the generic question but a lot of
people watching this will not seen the
movie yet so can you sort of talk a
little bit about what it's about the
movie is about a character Sarah played
by me she works in a craft store she's a
bit socially isolated she grew up riding
horses she still has a strong connection
to her horse and she begins to have a
series of strange and very lucid dreams
and she begins to sort of lose her grip
on reality that's almost like you've
practiced that talking voice right um
one of the things I really dig about
this is that it is unlike other movies I
love original films and you guys
absolutely crafted one with this I also
like that there's an unreliable narrator
so a lot of people can watch this and
actually instead of me talking can talk
a little bit about the FEL the fact that
it's you know you have an unreliable
narrator and now you can that kind of
thing yeah definitely I think one of our
main objectives was to put the audience
in Sarah's shoes as she's going through
everything that she's going through she
spends a lot of the movie pretty
confused and terrified and having
trouble knowing what's real and what's
in her mind and we wanted the audience
going on that journey with her and and
empathizing with her and and really
being inside her head it gets to a point
where the audience really is meant to be
right inside her mind kind of seeing how
she's navigating it and I'm glad that
you felt that way for the two of you
this is was a very most people think
that you know you have a fully fleshed
out script and that you step on set and
you're doing those words with maybe a
little improv this that was not the case
making this movie could the three of you
sort of talk about that yeah I mean the
last three movies I've made I've been
working this way where we work off of a
pretty detailed outline without actually
writing the dialogue out but the beats
of what they're saying are generally in
the
descriptions of the outline and I just
found it's like a really useful way to
get performances that I feel like a
really fresh and present and sort of
unexpected and it keeps everyone on
their toes and it sort of just keeps
everyone engaged and I think it's if you
find the right actors you can pull it
off I think it's really rewarding I
actually enjoyed it I think it's like
freeing and it's not like it's like oh
we don't know what's gonna happen make
it up it's like it was a very detailed
outline and we basically knew what we're
gonna say so just like allows the dialog
to flow kind of naturally and I like to
make stuff up and goof off so it was
good and then we would shut it down and
meet it with John no goofing off yeah
this is a very serious we'll see tonight
have you seen it I have seen it I think
it's course you saw some small screen I
saw it on a small screen the optimal
place to watch it on your phones so
Apple watches like and subscribe
refrigerators and like dishwashers
there's the main venue yeah I have so
much to say about this but I want to act
I am curious that you do have a detailed
synopsis but I would imagine with the
improv process it allows for people to
maybe come up with some ideas you're not
expecting in the moment did you ever go
back to a scene you it shot and maybe
add something as a result of something
you learned during the shoot no because
given the schedule there's not really a
lot of time so like you have to be
really careful with this kind of stuff
and we were shooting out of order so you
have to kind of plan everything out
otherwise you paint yourself into a
crazy corner so we you know we would do
a scene maybe like a scene that would
happen later from something that we
anticipated would be going certain way
but then we realized if we do this it
can lead to this but you have to kind of
set it up like before it's too late you
can't really like change things up
there's no way we don't do reshoots no
time for that also the way that we wrote
the movie there's a lot of complex stuff
happening that that really have to do
with time the essence of time Sarah's
reality so we were tracking that very
closely and yeah I think it would be it
would be interesting being like and now
say whatever you want and then often
we'd come into the scenes to be like but
you do have to hit these specific things
because there's some major
points that we want the audience to
follow I'm always curious about the
editing room because that's the final
rewrite talk a little bit about maybe
what surprised you when you stepped in
the editing room and let's start with
that the main thing is when you're
shooting something you think everything
is absolutely essential and you don't
think you can lose anything at all and
everything is building towards this
thing but then when you start editing
you realize you know actually we can
lose this scene it's like you know
crisper and it flows better so there's
like probably three scenes or parts that
we kind of cut out that I thought would
be devastating to the film but and you
know after watching it you don't really
need it as much so
yeah that's like you you think you can
actually accomplish a lot more sometimes
and things then yeah I also feel like we
have a guest come in join us debby ryan
just say your name and height another
thing that I really think that we
noticed and this is speaking to what you
were saying earlier about this
unreliable narrator is like while we're
shooting it you know you're feeling like
oh the audience is really we want them
to be right there with Sarah through
everything she's experiencing but for a
lot of the movie I'm not talking much at
all I'm reading I'm like getting
information visually and we realized I
think in the Edit that the audience
wasn't actually getting that information
maybe until a couple scenes later we
didn't want them to be behind so I feel
like that was a big part of the editing
process kind of splicing in things so
you could really understand what I'm
thinking when I'm thinking it completely
for all four of you I would imagine
making this was both challenging and a
lot of fun if you could maybe share a
memory from this from filming something
like stands out you know whether it be a
crazy day whether it be just a fun day
whatever comes to mind
I think the main thing is this movie was
really intense movie to shoot but it was
also like the most joyful fun experience
I think I've ever had and something that
I thought was really beautiful was when
there were challenges instead of it you
know like falling down it's like placing
blame on someone who messed up everyone
kind of came together and there's this
one scene where there's light is
supposed to be coming in through her
bedroom door like a bright white light
and when we built the set the moldings
on the door we're kind of blocking out
light so and we had a shoot because
we're kind of crazy schedule so we had
like I think two minutes but
between so--that's make sure this thing
would work and like everyone from every
department like the grip the gaffer
production designers like set dresser
like I think it's maybe a Transpo guy
there was like jackhammering this
molding to get it off with like crowbars
and stuff and got it off like I have a
video of it but it's like amazing how
hard they were working and it was just
all hands on deck immediately no
hesitation no you know it was a lot of
heart
I was like its I mean I think people
obviously are a professional but you
don't always get like this level of
commitment and engagement from like
everyone from top to bottom
and it was absolutely like it was
amazing I think you know for me it was
very interesting as Jeff was saying you
know we shot out of order it was
basically we had to shoot by location so
at every location we'd get to we would
then shoot in order so every two to five
days I was like resetting to Sarah at
the beginning of the movie and then like
ramping up to some you know intense
stuff and so it was really fun you know
she's really isolated character - I feel
like the week that we shot with you - in
the apartment was the best thing to do
this reset and shoot the we I guess we
called it the party scene even though
it's only the four of us dancing and
like the characters are drinking and
smoking weed and like it's so out of
character for Sarah and we got to dance
I wish I mean in the original kind of
the movie I feel like our dance scene
was like 20 minutes long does it does it
does it rival ex machina and Oscar Isaac
I definitely saw it right and I believe
it does yeah I mean honestly this might
sound dumb but this was like one of the
chiller movies I've worked on and two
movies I've worked on actually though so
many actually amazing films but yeah
this was really chill and the hours were
cool everyone on set was cool Jeff kept
saying how much he loved the crew the
whole time which I thought was nice and
I would say one of my favorite scenes as
we shoot this scene in a cemetery and it
was at night and there were foxes
running around and
sort of baby foxes some were babies so
and that's that was even cuter but it
just added sort of a surreal vibe to
this already surreal movie so it was fun
to like act and then go sit in chairs
with the crew and it was just there was
a good nervousness and an anticipation
going into it not knowing what their
process was and knowing they sort of
were we lucked into it and had a
distinct vision and sort of knew what it
was going to be and not knowing how I
was gonna find my place in that was
daunting and then the second I got on
said it was so just like they were so
disarming and it was so cool and
collaborative and so informed by just
having the conversation and just finding
it and so the first day I went from like
just paralyzed with fear just being like
I were gonna see how this goes to by the
end of the day it was so chill it was so
encouraging and collaborative and I
remember that day at lunch they were
doing a thing where they would raffle
something off to a different crew member
every day I mean every day every day
every got it I'm a little bit curious
when you obviously are making this on a
limited schedule a limited budget
limited time so how does that sort of
affect like the amount of takes you get
to do on set is it one of these things
where it's like you know you really got
to do it in two or were there days you
know what I mean like how did yeah I
mean it's you got to do the calculus in
your head as it's happening but you know
having done it a couple times you sort
of know you could do triage in your head
and you're like yes of course I don't
want this thing to be perfect but like
you also kind of sacrifice things later
on so these guys are awesome and like
you time on micro-adjustments at that
point by like takes and if we got it we
got it of course like I wish we could go
you know 50 takes per thing but it's
also exhausting for actors and you know
it's you just it's it's just there's
there's a sort of flow to it and you
sort of feel like when it's okay but you
also don't want to like push it too hard
because it's going to end up like
sacrificing something later and what was
helpful and you talked about this before
in terms of the way that we do the
improvisation is like the dialogue is
pretty much locked in after you
the first few takes of the wide shot and
then we're pretty much staying you know
sometimes our script supervisor would
even type it up so we could look at it
and be like great that's what we just
said now we'll say it again so that made
it quicker when we got into coverage so
if you don't mind me asking so on all
the scenes are you doing the wide shot
first yeah it'll be like whatever if
there's three people I usually do like a
two or three so I don't really do like
master shots but it'd be like two or
three shot and then we do like three or
four takes find it figured and then lock
it in it's not like every single take is
like a mystery we're like where's it
gonna go we pretty much know what's
gonna happen from that point on and then
just get coverage and it's pretty
straightforward so it's not it's not
like as like who knows what's going to
happen it's it's like a little less go
with it and it's a little more like that
was great do that again plus this right
so by the time your close-up comes
you're ready to rock you're like I just
memorized the lines that I just made up
let's do it yeah we're all such huge
fans of glow at glider and I know this
is the upcoming last season what what
can you tease and when are you filming
oh goodness I don't think I can tease
anything because I truly don't know I've
been trying to apply it out you know
we're out of Vegas for sure so I know
that and we start shooting at the
beginning of March I'll be directing an
episode again this season so I can tell
you that thank you I really don't know i
mean i i'm i i'm assuming that debbie is
gonna be running her network that she
just bought and i'm very curious to see
where we find ruth on her journey and I
hope those ladies reunite as soon as
possible thank you all so much for
coming in thank you seriously I hope
everyone who's watching this ends up
when is it on Netflix February 7th right
so it's really soon I was gonna say
listen have a fantastic premiere I hope
everyone loves it I hope you film gets
old
obviously and but a huge thank you to
Kia again for being such an awesome
sponsor and Congrats on the movie guys
thank you so much thank you thank you